voilà pour les titres bienvenue à vous
si vous nous rejoignez sur France 24 le
président russe Vladimir Poutine vient
d'ordonner l'instauration de la loi
martiale dans les quatre territoires
Ukrainiens de donies
en septembre dernier à part Moscou
bonjour à vous Gulliver Craig en direct
depuis à qui avant en Ukraine Gulliver
est-ce que le président russe a tout
d'abord justifier cette décision
je n'ai pas entendu comment Vladimir
Poutine a justifié la décision je suis
désolé je peux commenter ce à quoi ça
ressemble vu de Kiev qui est bien sûr
dans le contexte de ce que les
Ukrainiens ont découvert dans les
régions qu'ils ont libérées au mois de
septembre par exemple la région de
harkif qui est que le régime mise en
place par les forces d'occupation russe
ça apporte déjà à une forme de loi
martiale arrestation arbitraire présence
de militaires dans les rues constamment
couvre-feu un couvre-feu est aussi en
place depuis 2014 dans les régions qui
sont des facto occupés par la Russie
depuis 2014 une partie des régions de
Tonneins et de loink et puis aussi de
manière juridique des jurés si vous
voulez la loi martiale est déjà en place
dans ces régions puisque c'est ce sont
des régions qui appartiennent à
l'Ukraine et l'Ukraine a déjà décrété
cette mesure au début de l'invasion
russe le 24 février alors concrètement
que cela va vraiment changer quelque
chose est-ce que cela veut dire quelque
chose difficile depuis que d'entrevoir
qu'est-ce que cela pourrait engager
en termes de changement de du
comportement des régimes d'occupation
russe dans ces régions alors des
opérations d'évacuation et je mets les
guillemets ont donc été annoncé par les
autorités russes à personne dans le sud
près de 60000 civils transférait vers la
Russie est-ce que la Gulliver on sait si
les questions de déplacement forcé de
population
c'est toute la question les autorités
ukrainiennes insistent que ce sont des
déplacements forcés et donc des
déportations qui selon Kiev constitue un
crime de guerre mais il est difficile de
confirmer je pense qu'on peut se poser
qu'une partie de ces populations veulent
bien partir vu que il est clair que
l'armée ukrainienne avance vers la ville
de Herson et des combats sont prévus
même si les Ukrainiens insistent qu'ils
vont tout faire pour essayer d'éviter de
blesser les civils ou d'endommager
l'infrastructure civile il est clair que
le danger est là l'Ukraine avait déjà
mise en garde les civils déjà au mois de
juillet les conseillons de quitter la
région mais plutôt de la quitter pour
venir vers la partie de l'Ukraine contre
les par Kiev je pense qu'il faut croire
qu'une partie des personnes aurait bien
voulu aller vers l'Ukraine ou bien
rester sur place et seront forcés de
partir par les Russes mais pour le
moment il est difficile de faire la part
entre les deux coordes vu de Kev en tout
cas
merci beaucoup Gulliver Gulliver
craquant direct depuis la capitale la
ukra